what makes comic book movies great
another question that depends on who you
ask
to me
my favorite comic book movies are the
ones that Embrace being a comic book
we've seen a really big pivot in this
over the last couple of years I think
Noland was the one who kind of changed
the game with this with
Batman Begins
because we then approached
superhero movies as being grounded in
the real world
and as much as I enjoyed Nolan's views
on that and his style and what he's done
with the characters
he's almost set up this this stage for
many comic book movies to fail because
we want them almost to be grounded in
reality now
and again going back to
my childhood and growing up as a kid of
the 80s
I grew up with Adam West Batman which is
like so silly and over the top
and then you had of course Christopher
Reeves with Superman
Tim Byrne was Batman and Batman Returns
and they all had this very much like
different world
I was escaping to a different world
and then Nolan came in and he was like
no it could be grounded in reality and
then we've seen this even with Joker
we've seen it with the Matt Reeves
Batman
where it's very grounded
and then on the other end of the
spectrum you got kind of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
that they've been trying to tie in real
world issues into this comic book space
but I I know I sound like I'm beating a
dead horse here but it all comes back
down to story
and characters
if a character is well developed whether
it's a comic book movie
or any type of movie you're going to
find an audience you're going to connect
people are going to connect right people
like Tony Stark
because he's a cool character but he's
also a well-developed character Robert
Downey Jr really made that character his
own and while a lot of people say that a
lot of Tony Stark is just Robert Downey
Jr
that's the way the character is written
it was written for him so you're just
you may be just watching him
but you've grown to like him and the
stories help Elevate him
and that's what's great about it so to
me
you you can have all these characters
it's what you do with their progression
how the movie starts where it goes in
the middle and How It Ends is whether
it's going to be a good comic book movie
or not is it going to leave you wanting
more are you going to want to see more
of this character because we all know
and unfortunately nowadays
one movie is Never Enough one movie is
never enough so as much as I like Joker
and I was hoping that joker was going to
be a one-off
there's a Joker 2 coming and it's going
to be a musical and all these people are
going to be in it
yeah I'm curious to see it don't get me
wrong but the reason why people
like that movie and why people connected
with that movie is that it again they
liked what
Joaquin Phoenix brought to the table
they like that character they liked the
way that it was written what what he was
able to do with that material so
everything else sure the visual style
everyone loved about it you know
everyone's referencing Oh Martin scorses
you look and all this stuff
but if you take Joaquin Phoenix out of
that
does the movie like what would that
movie be with another actor and that's
that's what you really you really got to
focus on is that character and who's I
guess also I should say whose cast is
that character
right because do those people
become the character that you want them
to be you get lost in Joaquin Phoenix as
Joker right we get that we like that
Iron Man we know it's Robert Downey Jr
and a lot of these movies with so many
characters nowadays
eternals I I don't mean to keep crapping
on this movie but like to me you have
too many actors
no character develop development no
story like where is this going I have no
idea I walked away from that movie If I
never seen those characters again I'd be
completely fine
but you you want to spend more time with
characters and character development is
so important especially in superhero
movies because you know that they're
going to keep making them
so like if if an actor is bad in a role
and the story doesn't work
it again doesn't matter the production
value doesn't matter the costumes
doesn't matter the hair and makeup
it's it's not going to win people over
and that's what you're seeing right now
I think with the phases this last phase
of Marvel is that you're seeing so many
things get thrown at you
you're seeing you're seeing Sam raimi's
fingerprints all over doctor strange but
yet people are complaining like oh did
this person not watch Wanda Vision
because Elizabeth Olsen is weird in this
movie she doesn't seem to like realize
what happened in one division
and what is Benedict Cumberbatch doing
here he was so different in this one
compared to how he was in the other
movies and you watch in a weird way even
Thor right it's like okay like he's he's
out of shape and now like all of a
sudden like he's back in shape and like
a montage
I don't know they're losing the the
writing it's becoming
style over substance is what I've what
I've been seeing with Marvel phase four
is style over substance there's so much
style and they're trying to combine
these two ideas like there's a taika
with TT movie here and then there's the
Marvel movie here there's a Sam Raimi
movie here and then there's the Marvel
movie here and you you really need to
believe in your director and your cast
and your screenwriters to tell the story
they want us to tell I mean this kind of
takes me back to
you know Zack Snyder right I mean
Zack Snyder's Justice League that came
out on HBO Max after fan support for
like seemed like almost a decade but it
was only like five years but the
outpouring of support was because
everyone who knew Zack Snyder knew that
that movie that they put in theaters
wasn't his vision
and they weren't happy about it and
that's why there was so much of a fight
for it because
these are beloved characters that people
know that literally
decades upon Decades of comic books were
written about and yes he didn't follow
the formula that probably Warner
Brothers wanted
but he wanted to tell his vision and
they they mess with his vision
and that's the thing about his movies
that I respect him about
you can watch Man of Steel
you can watch Batman v Superman you can
watch
just new Justice League the complete
four-hour cut of it
and you can hate it it's completely fine
but at least you know it's the movie
that he wanted to make I think it's
really bad for comic book movies
nowadays when you feel like a director
is being dictated what they're doing
they're not they don't have creative
control they get partial creative
control and then it's almost like
someone steps in it's like no no no no
no you gotta do this this this and this
as long as you do this this and this you
can keep going and it just becomes a
tonal mess and I I it's weird and I'm
saying this because
Marvel was always the leg up on DC for
like a long time there because they had
a formula and I'm not saying that movies
every movie needs a formula
but right now it's just like it's so
inconsistent I I walk out of a movie and
I just kind of go oh okay like I'm like
this this was awesome this was terrible
like I really don't know like
the last like two or three Marvel movies
were like five out of tens for me
because I'm like I like things so much
about these but I hate so much about
these
so yeah it's it's I think it's changed
so much over the years you know because
again you go into the the time of the
80s and 90s where it was like camping
and it really sort of like really
Embrace what a comic book movie was and
it wasn't worried about the reality and
now we're kind of with the spectacle
we're with the substance and I think
it's really you know and this is no no
criticism because I think Nolan was
great Christopher Nolan did such a great
job of telling in such a grounded story
that you really felt like this could
happen anywhere but in a weird way it
almost like no one knew how to react to
it because you only have one Christopher
Nolan that's the thing with him as a
filmmaker he has a very unique vision
so he can tell a story and I think a lot
of people try to replicate that even
with the spectacle and he can't match it
because for him what always came first
was yes it's a big big scale movie but
he always cared about the story he
always cared about the characters and he
picked the right actors to play those
characters
again even a smaller comic book movie uh
American Splendor yes so Paul Giamatti
as Harvey pankar or oh my God yeah I
mean he he from when you saw a little
bit you heard some of his voice and
different things and and you can go back
to Old Letterman uh interviews and and
you felt like that was him he really
like embodied this guy this this guy
that was in this tough spot that felt
trapped in his life and and felt like he
wasn't going to be able to do anything
but be this file clerk yeah that's a
great movie by the way that was that was
another one that I saw very early on uh
and I I just love that that film I mean
Paul Giamatti speaking of comic book
movies remember when he was in that
Spider-Man movie and so underused and
never used again yeah it was very
bizarre but yeah Paul Giamatti is still
one of the greatest actors working today
sure so it sounds like for lack of a
better term if an actor's actor is is
the main character is this superhero or
whatever anti-hero whatever then then it
works but if it's too surface of a
performance it's not gonna yeah I mean
that's that's that really is a great
point and a great way of looking at
things it's like does the actor fit the
role
like do they Encompass what this
character is
you know and that's why I mean there's
always been this debate about Batman
right but like to me Michael Keaton will
always be the best Batman because I
literally just felt like he brought
himself to the performance just like you
can never tell me that Robert Downey Jr
wasn't like the perfect Iron Man there's
just certain actors that become these
characters and I know that they have
these different versions of them the
only one that's really weird that like
every actor who's kind of Taken on
besides Jared Leto
um is Joker
like Joker for some reason whoever takes
on that character brings something
unique to it
you know I mean even going back to Cesar
Romano right from like I mean the
cheesiness and the over top clowniness
of that
he was great as that character then you
got Jack Nicholson in the role you got
Heath Ledger and I'm gonna skip over
Carolina and go right to Joaquin Phoenix
like every one of those were like so
uniquely different and I think with
Batman right it's it's kind of like the
mystery of like it but like
only
Michael Keaton was able to balance the
Bruce Wayne and the Batman
where like you watch Robert Pence and
his Batman and he's he's good at Batman
Bruce Wayne yeah you know and I we don't
have to talk about George Clooney he's
another one we could just go and get out
glance over you know Val Kilmer was
probably you know again that was more
again coming back to the script like
that was a not a great script that he
had to work with
but you know he tried and then Christian
Bale I feel like again great Bruce Wayne
the Batman he never got the voice down
Christian Bale as great of an actor as
he is I just felt like he never got that
that voice down and which is why he's
always being made fun of like uh I'm
Batman you know like everyone always
like jokes about that because he just he
wasn't able to fully get it so that's
why I always say that Michael Keaton is
is his top dog for Batman how about
Margot Kidder Lois Lane
she embodied Lois Lane yeah yeah I think
so I mean and that's the the big
disconnect right with a lot of people
had with
um oh my God Amy Adams with Lois Lane
right like
she didn't really become the character
she didn't really get enough depth
and enough story she just kind of like
was underdeveloped a character that is
so iconic and so well known and loved
and how many Superman TV shows have
there been and like all this thing
Superman and Lois Lois and Clark like
all this stuff there's been all these
stories and
that that character really deserves to
have someone really do them Justice on
the big screen because I don't know
you're right since going back to the
original Superman I don't know if anyone
is has ever played that character well
that's interesting because everything
Amy Adams does otherwise I haven't seen
that performance so I can't speak to it
but I love her and everything yeah else
that she does so I don't know I'll have
to actually watch it and see yeah yeah
it's not that she's mad in it it's just
that it's a character that's not written
well I mean it's it's almost like
going into the superhero conversation
it's it's almost like Wonder Woman
Wonder Woman 1984.
Wonder Woman and Zack Snyder's Justice
League okay so Wonder Woman as a movie
up until the last Act is is
badass like I don't know I mean Gal
Gadot in that performance is just so
great she embodies the role she becomes
that character and she inspired so many
you know young girls I mean I just
remember that press day coming out and
like how many people you know little
girls and women were like so empowered
by her performance
and then you you see her in Zack
Snyder's Justice League and she's she's
again she's she's that way
and then I don't know what happened in
1984 like I'm not someone who hates that
movie I know a lot of people hate that
movie
but she's like she's there and the rest
of the movie's failing her she's like
doing her her best to make this stuff
work but she's got Pedro Pascal like
Hamming it up up to 30 like a 90 I don't
know what he's doing that movie there's
like this weird rock story line and then
you know let alone when the critics got
got all over it was there's like
subjective rape or some stuff with rape
going on in the movie which like I
didn't even like bother paying attention
to but like she did she became you know
because of that you know and I credit
Zack Snyder for that because Zack Snyder
took the chance Patty you know Patty
Jenkins put her in the the first movie
that really got her shine
but Zack's Niner hired her he's the one
who saw the potential
and and and made her the character and
then Patty Jenkins pushed her to the
next level and then in a weird way kind
of pushed threw it down the stairs in
the next movie so uh I I don't know and
again I don't hate 1984. I just think
it's a missed opportunity but I I felt
so I was thinking about that movie and I
feel so bad for for Gago though because
she's sitting there and she's trying so
hard at the end of that movie and she's
really pouring her heart and soul into
that performance and she's really great
in it but it's just like that script
that script it's not good it's not good